And you know,
one of the things that Carl Young pointed out was that he had this idea that
when science,
that that elk,
you know,
alchemy is the root of science in some sense,
it's the dream like sub straight out of which science emerged.
And,
but alchemy was kind of a weird ad mixture of religious thinking and scientific
thinking because those two things hadn't been differentiated back when there
were alchemists.
And you don't believe that what had happened in,
in Europe,
at least first was that the scientific and developing me blew up and expanded at
an exponential rate.
And that led to this advanced technological civilization that we have.
But that the moral dimension that was embedded in the religious symbolism,
it didn't develop at all.
And so we're in this unstable situation where we're far more technologically
proficient than we are wise.
And that that's actually a big problem because obviously the more powerful the
tools you generate,
the more intelligent ethically you better be or things are going to really,
uh,
are,
are going to go to hell in a hand basket very,
very rapidly.
You know,
and I had this thought,
I think I shared it a little bit last night,
that,
you know,
in the next five years,
six years,
we're going to develop pretty viciously intelligent AI systems.
And that's already happening.
You know,
I mean,
they're monitoring youtube and they're monitoring Facebook and they're
monitoring Google and they're trying to make ethical decisions,
these AI systems.
And the problem is,
is that the ethical presuppositions of the programmers are being embedded into
the infrastructure of the net.
And that's a hell of a thing to think because it means that for better or worse,
we're building automated intelligence is that reflect our own morality.
And we better be very careful about what our morality is if we're going to
automate it.
Because automated systems are incredibly powerful.
So,
so that's,
that's kind of,
that's where we're at,
at least to some degree in terms of the new technological transformations with
in communication technology,
you know,
it puts each of us at the,
at the center of a wide web of connections and makes the consequences of our
moral decisions much more immediately manifest to each of us.